- [Film Crew Member] Do we have sound speed?
- [Film Crew Member] Sound rolling.
- Ready, Kirk?
- Okay.
- [Film Crew Member] Roll picture.
(old-fashioned music)
- The Smithsonian's National Museum
of Natural History has
over 144 million objects.
Like this narwhal tusk.
(old-fashioned music)
My name's Kirk Johnson.
I'm in charge of all of them.
99 percent of the collections
are behind the scenes,
and these are the people
that work with them.
This is Carla Dove, from
the Division of Birds.
- [Carla] Here in the Division of Birds
we have somewhere around
620,000 museum specimens.
And that represents about 85 percent
of the diversity of birds in the world.
You look at these specimens
and you realize that
this is where the science
is really gonna start.
We're using our collections
to identify birds
that collide with airplanes,
and help us improve aviation safety.
- [Kirk] Dr. Bob Robbins,
curator of butterflies and moths.
- [Bob] I have been
professionally employed
as a lepidopterist who
works on butterflies
for about 35 years.
This is the essence of my being,
is to know everything about butterflies.
There's a whole world out there that,
unless you look very
closely, you don't see.
And it's a interesting world,
it's a fascinating world,
and it is full of practical
value for human beings.
- This is Ellen Strong,
curator of mollusks.
- [Ellen] What I love about
this collection is its breadth.
We estimate that we may have
as many as 20 million specimens.
We are preserving
a record of past life on this planet,
of present life on this planet,
and preserving that for the future.
I take that responsibility very seriously.
And providing access,
and caring for the
specimens for posterity.
- Dr. Jeff Post,
curator of the national
gem and mineral collection.
- [Jeff] Minerals in this collection
go from something that formed
maybe in the last few tens of years
to others that formed more
than three billion years ago.
We know right now there
are more than 5,000
minerals that make up the Earth.
And in our collection we probably have
more than half of those.
Each one's a little piece of the puzzle.
We try to put all these things together
and hopefully, eventually
understand the big picture
of how the Earth works.
- And Floyd Shockley,
collection manager for entomology.
- [Floyd] We have just a little over
35 million specimens in the collection.
A third of all of insect life on Earth
is represented by at least one specimen
in our collection.
When you look at a
collection the size of ours,
you're starting to get to a point
where you can ask really big questions,
the questions related to
global climate change,
habitat destruction.
And you can only answer
those big questions
if you have a lot of specimens
collected over a long period of time
from a lot of different species.
- To understand the Earth
and the living things of the Earth,
you need to collect those things
and preserve them and study them.
And that helps you when you need food,
or when you have a disease.
All that stuff arcs back
to the fact that we have samples
of the whole planet here.
And that's how we understand the planet.
(bright music)
(chiming music)